[Music]
in shady Khan news and this is submitted
by love from New York New York hey a
woman
instagrams getting her hairdresser drunk
to steal hair I thought of you
immediately then oh man I understand no
man extension how much do they go for it
depends on what you want yeah I mean so
like back in the day right legit if you
just wanted like 10 inches extensions
right like the cheapest human it'll be
like $5.99 back in the day this is like
maybe five no like six bucks but now
even our cheapest packs go for $20 now
so you could imagine how much the higher
in chin it sound like there's indian
remy hair right so indian remy hair can
go up to like 300 bucks 400 bucks a pack
Wow is that you get used to run their
story okay so like that's not including
what it costs just to get your hair done
maintenance and everything else out
laughter that too so you have to realize
to have to get your hair done after like
two three weeks you got to get it done
again you gotta get it done again so you
gotta realize when black when we get
their hair done
it's [ __ ] expensive mm-hmm it's
[ __ ] expense that's right don't get a
wet man yeah straight up yeah don't yeah
you will see [ __ ] like it's funny at
her school right where it rains and it
was a supposed to rain these girl
[ __ ] like I have taken a shirt off of
a man's back and that's just like Alice
in Wonderland with the mushroom a [ __ ]
they're trying to find anything thank
you expensive man yeah so this woman her
name is Amy she posted a couple of video
cuz she posted it yeah and she's just
saying she's the most savage 28 I know
this girl I saw this do you know but you
know put the scroll away no she did yep
all right so her caption before I show
you the video her caption is mr. Chow
Ling you messed up by flirting with me
at Chapel beauty supply store now I got
in my house and on the Hennessy and I'm
taking all your bundles for free
you've been finessed ladies hit my petty
ass up for the hash tag bundles who's
mr. Chow Ling the beauty supply store
person we don't even know that's really
it's your uncle
I know [ __ ] well that's kind of
weird if he really is oh that's her I
will say this though the blacker the
berry the sweeter the juice
well that's all got wait what's wrong
with this eyes she's kind of pretty too
no it's just the you'll see right now
here you go does she have an Instagram
filter on them okay that means an issue
for her finesse you take your hair plug
thank you he's here again take another
shot all week he'll be on the Hennessy
ladies we are getting free bundles we
are not paying for hair anymore
what the [ __ ] he's drunk as [ __ ]
thank you so they get them drop off all
right ladies if you need to learn any
more game feel free to DM me and I'll
let you know how you get the plug for
the house
what is gonee
so she's telling him I'm conning you and
the plug is like you're connect like
your connection so she conned some hair
yeah if she's telling him in his face
yes I'm stealing from you but what she
saw what is she's so proud of she giving
him a she's getting him back no cuz
she's just saying like hey look I'm I'm
conning this dude in front of his face
that's all slick I actually Eddie does
even though he doesn't even know I will
say this I am NOT disappointed in that
girl I am disappointed in that asian man
who the [ __ ] gives away free [ __ ] at a
store what Asian are you well let me
show you the second video all I'm saying
is we disowned in her she's not
I didn't like that at all yeah so for
the second video this is what she
captioned it it says that's a lot of
[ __ ] to say you want to read it oh I
don't know cuz this [ __ ] make me
uncomfortable
all right hair stylist and hair plug
below I'm the biggest savage of 2018
used to pay for another bundle of hair
so I decided to invite my hair plug over
and get him drunk I'm making him
transfer his hair account into my name
as we speak
thank you mister yeah shall we eat a dog
wing she said I hope it's not a criminal
offense yeah I hope this isn't a
criminal offense but this weave is just
getting too expensive mr. Chow Ling
don't know he just mailed five hundred
free but okay 500 free bundles of hair
oh I like I don't understand what goes
through her head to make her think that
she can invite somebody to her house and
then all of his [ __ ] is gone you know
that's currently your mix girls I got
something big wall never you never hear
blacker I got everything gone I must
admit though that hair looks great all I
was gonna say it's very high quality
hair I mean I take it back basically she
said and then he was like oh thank you
very much I don't know if she did that
we we she did the week so that's why I
was repeating it cuz it's somebody you
guys didn't catch all my been saying in
the video she's like yeah you know I
just let him see me a little here but
but then so that's why a lot of people
are commenting like is it a condo cuz he
might have just got some [ __ ] - yeah
yeah that's what that's called a trade
yeah people are saying like yeah those
these hair plugs don't cost that much in
China it's pretty cheap for him to get
it so who looks you got okay idea what
if she really did [ __ ] him for the hair
right and she's so embarrassed about it
that she doesn't wanna tell anybody so
then she puts on like this I'm a hard
[ __ ] cold let him decide because I find
it so hard to believe that the do would
just give it to her I'm pretty sure he
got a little [ __ ] yeah and then that's
why he gave her them go back to the
first wait was he tired was he like
he looks like he just nut it though oh
yeah the room though you can hear a
third person damn she [ __ ] yeah so you
[ __ ] a really old Chinese guy for some
hair that's kind of sad I feel bad for
you now but your body is crazy yeah I
know I'm just watching the whole time
like dress and your hair is nice and but
you're so mean yeah well kind of covered
here but yeah her face is pretty too
that she ya know she started but your
personalities mean she is me but if she
did [ __ ] that old Chinese man you're a
saint she didn't even have to do mmm-hmm
she didn't have to do all that she could
have just been like oh she says her
boobs are great
ya know cuz like her arms do yeah girl
I'm great
like Conda got caught is something very
but that means that's unbeknownst to
that guy but he knew what he was doing
though cuz he got something from her
that's not a con he didn't even have to
speak exactly he didn't con anybody
really if she if she thinks that she's
such a great con Aria you didn't caught
it because she he received something for
what you did and yeah to go to your
house it doesn't make any sense why did
he go to your house exact a con is like
you tricked it and somehow you got all
this [ __ ] without him knowing okay
that's the most interesting exchange
like here's some fake hair to look at my
body you probably gave her something
leftover [ __ ] too
I mean you work with what you got it
might worked in some places that's her
currency right there her body's our
currency hmm I'll show you my left
nipple
if you sing me a song there's a lot of
girls that do [ __ ] like that oh that's
true like for a drink - yeah they will -
or for like a bag yeah absolutely
sex for a drink Oh people will suck dick
for a long I use the work at TGI Fridays
so people who suck dick for a Long
Island we were I gotta go where you live
it was a ticket it'd be great hair in
one hand what a Long Island this is
neither one works
damn dude I didn't know it was that easy
I'm sure he thought raisins either yeah
I think she went she racist I mean
that's a very good middle name you eat
dog no that's no eat it up you know
what's so I don't like I think it's so
interesting like especially like in like
today's society where you know racism is
like highlighted you can't really get a
pass on anything right and you expect
some a woman from a culture who has been
so like disenfranchised with like racism
you wouldn't use those terms for
somebody else
oh yeah you wouldn't pass it on it
almost hurts more you know what I mean
so it's like you said we're supposed to
be on the same team yeah but you took
all the negative that happened to you
and you want to just pass it on to
somebody else but the funny thing is
she's a con right and she's proud of
being a con
you can't expect expect them to have
like this non really don't come up like
[ __ ] I don't care that's not what I
did I came up I think that she [ __ ]
him and she was embarrassed about yeah
yeah but see if she had filled a video
and she was like yo I just [ __ ] this
dude and I got this whole bag of hair
like I would be like good for you like
you've actually liked her even more
exactly good for him too yeah and I'm
still still yeah good for him because
there's a lot of Instagram models a lot
of Instagram models that little
fourteen-year-old girls look up to and
what they don't know is these girls are
getting pooped on by princes all over
the world you know like this I want to
see like then you I want a news anchor
to go to mr. Ling or whatever his house
and just open the door and you know how
do you feel about the situation just
goes right I got [ __ ] [ __ ] what do you
want for me she's probably still [ __ ]
him too I know she has the nicest
titties I've ever seen
[ __ ] you know for such a long time that
she earned that whole box in fact she
probably in love at this point you don't
know
[Music]
[Music]